a warren urges biden to bypass congress
and cancel
student debt kai do you want to pull up
that article if you already have it so
biden's saying ten thousand dollars
is what i wanted to pay maybe we'll go
up to forgiven fifty thousand dollars
but elizabeth warren is saying let's
just cancel all
of student debt meaning all 1.5 trillion
dollars of it
forgive all of it is what she is saying
president-elect
biden also already committed we
interpret government government okay so
we know that part
uh cancelled billions of dollars of
student loan debt
he can cancel billions of dollars of
student loan debt giving tens of
millions of
of americans an immediate financial
boost and helping to close the racial
wealth gap
this is the single most effective
executive
action available for massive economic
stimulus biden harris can lower the drug
okay so
go on that part do you have the stats
because this is what ben shapiro said go
to ben shapiro which i totally agree
with them
how about this instead of forgiving
everybody's college debt we force
all of them kai can you move please
we force all the colleges who scam
millions of americans into degrees in
useless theory
masquerading as valuable life skills to
grant refunds
that would end the grift right quick i
agree with them
did you get that data i asked you for
last night can you pull up that data so
okay here's what it looks like
1987 1988 a four-year college degree
costs you nine thousand dollars okay
this is 2017 okay so a non-profit a a uh
a public a private was twenty two
thousand and then it went all the way up
to today the nine thousand dollars today
is twenty one thousand dollars the nine
thousand
the twenty two thousand dollars is forty
six thousand dollars and that's just
college tuition and that's
that that number is very small by the
way kai uh
this is per year not uh four years per
year is what we're looking at
from 22 000 to 46 thou colleges went
from being a place you went to to get a
degree to now be in a business model
third these numbers are averages while
the 2017 2018 median
private non-profit prices was in 35 000.
10 of full-time students attended
institutions with prices below 12 000
and 13 attempt institutions charging 51
000 or more
13 are paying more than 200 000 for
their four-year
of college in terms of percentage the
price of public education has jumped 130
percent
the price of private education has
jumped up 111 percent
kai can you can we look at one thing can
we look at one thing
um what does it look like uh the other
data i asked
yesterday was what the endowment of
universities do you have that the
endowment of universities this is top 10
endowment make it a little bigger
harvard's sitting on 41 billion dollars
41 billion dollars worth they're sitting
on right now endowment cash
yale is sitting on 30 billion stanford
sitting on 28 billion give or take
princeton 25 26 billion mit sitting on
17 billion
university of pennsylvania sitting on
14.6 say 15 billion texas a m's got 13
billion
michigan's got 12.2 billion notre dame's
got 11.5 billion
columbia university's got 11 billion
dollars
they're worried about making college
more available
to the average american why not go
pressure universities to lower prices
when they're sitting on so much cash
themselves
what do you think about what elizabeth
warren's saying you know what
the first question i have when i hear
elizabeth warren saying that
from my perspective is how can anybody
take her serious or how can you
follow her but man i get it i mean if
you have student debt
and she comes out and say let's just
wipe it clean i mean i can see how that
message
appeals to younger people it's it's
unbelievable when you consider the cost
and then that's not even counting
textbooks
have you ever looked i mean they nickel
and dime these kids left and right
textbooks it's a 10 billion dollar
industry
10 billion dollars is what kids spend
you know what a 10 billion dollar
industry is
major league baseball that's a 10
billion dollar industry
gucci that's 10 billion every single
year so it's staggering
and you know look at the salaries of the
people that run those endowments they're
making
five six seven million dollars a year
insane from 1978 till today the price of
textbook has increased eight hundred and
twenty
twelve percent yeah kai what was the dow
jones ad go go dow jones 1980 go
dow jones 1980 1980.
is that what 880 let's say 891
and today's at what
29 down 29.649 what is the number there
i'm curious because if it's if it
matches
okay why don't you do this go to median
income 1980
median income 1980 1980.
is that what 21 336 and median income
today
hasn't gone up much no median that's a
lower income class go to median income
so median income go a little lower uh
uh statistic click on that to see what
it shows okay right there right on the
below go a little lower to the bottom go
back
go back and go to the lower link right
there
stanford yep see what it shows us here
this is stanford
they're fairly reasonable 1980
income median income household
where is it showing that 1980 can you
see it is that about 20 yeah say 20. so
numbers about right 20 thousand dollars
and where is it at today
2020 go median income so 28 1980 it
shows median income around 20 000
what is 2020 median income it's like 46
is that what it was i think it's higher
than that median income
national median income right now 78
hundred so
seventy eight thousand five hundred so
income has increased
give it two hundred percent two hundred
and fifty percent
from 1980 till today prices of books
have increased eight hundred and ten
percent how do you keep up with that
i mean it's a business model right now
if you're selling textures yeah totally
and i think it's a scam i mean what do
you even need books for
i mean my daughter's 14 years old when
she was going to school everything's
home now
i can't believe how heavy her backpack
is and this is for a freshman in high
school
college multiply that by 10. the the
bulk of the books
everything's digital now i think it's a
scam to keep you know hard copy books
where you're hammering the kids
for 1200 bucks it's unbelievable
who protects that industry democrats are
republicans
who protects that industry by the way go
back to that last stat
michigan university in uh minimum go to
right there let's play some numbers
1987. can you highlight that so the
viewer can see it 1987 michigan state uh
university the per credit hour rate was
and 25 cents per credit hour assuming a
full year of 30 credits amounts to 1
477 in tuition in 2017 the per credit
hour is 480 to 10 times more
with an estimated 30 annual credits of
14 000 460.
1987 is what 33 years ago is that about
33 years ago 33 years ago it's gone up
10x
in 33 years that's a lot of money right
there so who
protects universities is it more
democrats independents or republicans i
would i would
my hunch would be it's democrats it's
democrats that protect them a little bit
more because they're preaching the
language
they're basically preparing kids to come
out into the world to be democrats so i
would imagine that they if you had to
pick one of them
but you know these universities and this
whole college system
they protect themselves i mean they know
look at the ncaa basketball tournament
who gets rich off that the kids don't
you know uh it's it's the universities
that make so much money
will muschamp who was the head coach for
south carolina college sports
terrible you know he got fired this year
they were like two and five right
horrible head coach walks away with 15
million dollars
i mean it's just colleges in general
it's a house of cards i think on some
levels and especially
when when the world's changing because
of coronavirus
and what are they going to do for
tuition in the following years if you're
making kids do this virtually
how can you char they do they charge the
same amount of tuition
these private schools they're doing the
exact same thing but
you're going to see some things here man
because
there's a tipping point at some point
and you can't that's why this lockdown
is so bad anybody that thinks
a lockdown's good it's going to slow
down coronavirus that's what they said
last spring
and it didn't work it didn't stop the
curve it didn't do
anything so that's why i don't believe
this one will be effective and it's just
another way to give in to what they're
trying to do to you
and with no end in sight what are your
thoughts
education well my oldest son the doctor
would love to see this because when he
graduated med school he owed over four
hundred thousand dollars
you know i'm a cop my wife was a nurse
we didn't have the money to pay for his
college education not his not his
is it true that for the first 10 years
or so the interest rates are pretty low
and and are they kind of easy on these
kids or are the payments starting big
right out of the gate for them well you
do get a waiver until you're
gainfully employed but you know his
monthly
student loan payment is as high as his
mortgage payment
if not higher so i know he would love to
see this wave but
who you know the bottom line is who
bears the brunt of that who absorbs that
cost
if we waive all that the taxpayers of
course
and where does their money come from
taxes right so the ultimate thing is the
taxpayers end up paying for this
he understands when he took those loans
he had a responsibility to pay it back
he's okay with that i mean it doesn't
like making that check every month
but he agreed to that all the other
students agreed to that so why are we
waving that now
and another thing is if you go to the
just like you said the sports programs
i love college football i don't no
longer watch professional sports but
i love college football and i was scared
to death we weren't going to have it
this year
well it's such a big proponent of all or
a big part of all the colleges the major
colleges
we're all watching it again on the
weekends aren't we so and then you look
at the colleges there's there's not a
college that i can think of that you go
to and
hungry and i were on the college circuit
for quite a while speaking to
major universities and colleges around
the country every college campus we went
to
had new construction ongoing you gotta
you can't have you can't build things if
you don't have the money and when you
look at the numbers you just put up on
the screen holy cow i had no
idea it was that big what what is
elizabeth warren's plan
after you wipe out all the debt what
about the next generations of kids that
want to go to college
are they then taking out loans that in
15 or 20 years you wipe all that out as
well
i mean it's it's quite a rallying cry to
say hey let's just wipe out all
student debt trillions of dollars i mean
it's unbelievable
again personal acceptance responsibility
you made an agreement when you borrowed
that money that you'd pay it back
pay it back but i bet it's too high i
mean something has to happen here where
it can be a little bit more affordable
i guess especially state university i
guess the thing being becomes is it more
waive it and put the pressure on
taxpayers or put the pressure on
universities
or put the price there's only three
candidates here you got to put the
pressure on right three people here
one is the student who took on the debt
no one like you said it's responsibility
you knew what you were taking on when
you took that sallie mae
or whoever the loan is with right okay
is it their responsibility
is it the college's fault for charging
too much or
let the rest of the taxpayers take on
that one and a half trillion dollars and
say look we'll just pay the bill don't
worry about it
whose responsibility is it if you were
to put it in order
definitely not the government number one
i don't think i would say you you have
to start with everybody knows what
they're getting in for
right when you go to college you
understand when you take those loans
that that's part of you you knew that
right so i would say that would be
number one
and then anything else i think would be
gravy any way you can help these kids if
you're
looking at these staggering loans but i
don't think it's it'd be nice if the
colleges could find a way to do it but
they won't
and when did colleges become a
for-profit company
oh that's been around for it never to
this level no no doubt about it of
course
never to this level but you know you
said you watch college football but you
don't watch
by the why don't you watch pros you said
you don't watch pros that's a whole
nother topic
is it political
i guess it is i guess it is it's i don't
agree with you know
god bless these people you know they the
anybody involved in professional sports
you have attained the level of expertise
in a particular field
that most of us can't attain or we're
not dedicated enough to attain that
level
but the bottom line is it's a game it's
a game we can live without games in our
lives
for you to stand up and make political
statements out of of your
your fame because you're a sports figure
i just don't agree with that
so is it fair to say you have a painting
of lebron james in your house somewhere
[Laughter]
probably not probably not yeah okay